let's say you've given up your
law-abiding lifestyle to pursue a life
of crime you've just made your first big
score perhaps from selling drugs taking
a bribe or other corrupt acts
you can't just spend it or deposit it in
your bank account without attracting
attention from authorities that pesky
money trail might serve as evidence of
the crime you committed so you need to
get that dirty money clean there are
three steps to any money laundering
scheme first up
placement where funds are moved from
direct association with the crime then
layering or disguising the money trail
to foil any authorities and finally
integration where the funds are once
again available to spend without worry
of being caught so what are your options
one option is forming a shell company
it's fairly easy and there are plenty of
law firms who can help it should take
them only a bit longer than signing up
for a new email address launderers may
turn to historic tax havens like
Switzerland or places where you can set
up anonymous shell companies like the
Cayman Islands or the US states of
Delaware and Nevada once a shell company
is set up make up some fake transactions
for goods or services that you pay for
with your dirty money suddenly that
dirty money looks legitimate it also
helps to find people in banking who
don't care if you're a shady client
after the fall of the Soviet Union
launderers sought out weak spots
throughout Europe where oversight was
poor billions have been funneled through
banks in Cyprus Malta and the Baltic
nations of Estonia and Latvia if you
prefer to use the stock market you can
try a technique called mirror trading in
this method you use your money to
purchase shares and then you sell shares
worth the same amount somewhere abroad
the trades functionally cancel each
other out
but you've successfully turned your
rubles in to clean euros a similar
method is a back-to-back deal where say
a Russian takes out a loan in one
country say Austria that's guaranteed by
a deposit of dirty money back home in
Russia
she then defaults on the loan the bank
in Austria seizes the Russian deposit
but she still ends up with the proceeds
of the loan no strings attached or maybe
you like to visit casinos another method
of money laundering is mixing dirty
money in with clean cash businesses like
restaurants and casinos are particularly
attractive to launderers a common scheme
is to buy
bunch of casino chips make a few small
wagers then cash everything else out as
winnings or finally there's smurfing
though you won't need anything blue to
get your green with this one you hire a
bunch of associates called Smurfs two
individually deposit small chunks of the
large haul you're trying to cleanse in
different accounts in different places
the where US banks are required to
report any transaction over $10,000 so
you might need to find a lot of Smurfs
so you can see there's lots of ways to
launder money unfortunately for you
there's no guarantee that you won't get
caught
[Music]
you